[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today all right
let's go to David in Colorado Springs
hey David welcome to the
show good to talk to you guys how are
you doing absolutely we're great we're
glad that you called us David how can we
help okay um make a long story short um
my stepdaughter has really been into
figure skating since she was about six
years old and about a year and a half
ago she decided she wanted to start
competing so we're like well we we'll
give it a year see if she sticks with it
and she really has and she started
competing last year and is doing great
the issue is that we are kind of on the
low end of spending for this Sport and
it's costing us almost $1,000 a month oh
goodness and it just goes up from there
um having more coaching working with a
physical trainer uh starting to travel
having to pay for the coach to travel to
competitions and we're we really are
probably over our budget with what we're
spending now but at the same time she
really loves this and we're kind of
trying to figure out how do you balance
her loving the sport and us not going
broke man how old is she now she is 14
okay I I've got some unpopular opinions
on this that I always get in trouble for
can I just put them out there is that
cool John stirs the pot in all I me very
few things do I get in more trouble from
the internet people than this but here
we go um I would
suggest that we've grown up in a culture
we've created a culture where the kid is
the star of the family
show and ultimately where do you want to
eat what do you want to do who do you
want to become what do you want to be
when you grow up what college do you
want to go to what's your dream school
we dump all of these things in our kids
backpack think of them as rocks we just
drop them in our kids and what happens
without meaning to and this happens like
us trying to love and honor and give our
kids opportunities that we didn't have
they end up carrying the weight of the
whole
house and I dude I'm a product of sports
I played Sports all the way through I
was a two sport Letterman I ran in
college I did MMA with professionals
like I'm all about sports and teams and
workouts and discipline all that stuff's
great and the greatest gift I can give
my kid is not mortgaging my soul and our
future and literally a second literally
a second mortgage that some people do to
pay for this stuff yeah to let them
quote unquote do whatever they want or
do whatever they're passionate about do
whatever they what feels right the
greatest gift I can give them is a
stable at peace Mom and Dad that's the
greatest gift
and so before I get down a road where
I'm paying for private coaching I got to
fly the coach in or drive the coach in
now we got to do this it it just starts
building and like you said a little bit
of success breeds this and if you try to
back out it's like it's like a a time
share salesman right they're like hey
but we see really a bright future with
your daughter and if you do this then it
could lead to this and it could lead to
this and you your daughter's just
sitting there looking at you and you
feel like you feel like the Antichrist
pulling some of the stuff away and so I
always think it's as to not follow the
rabbit down the rabbit hole on this but
it's to start all the way at the
beginning with your wife and say hey
what kind of home do we want to have and
we're going to reverse engineer it that
way and what can we actually afford so
takes ice skating away and input
Lexus if she was really passionate about
Alexus and really a good driver and you
couldn't afford Alexus you wouldn't buy
her
Alexus but for some reason Sports have
become the altar that we sacrifice our
families on and that we allow our
families and our kids to worship and I I
I think it's beyond Madness it's gone to
pathology now um and at the same time
dude I get it I can't imagine having a
daughter who's starting to excel you're
a stepdad You're Building relationships
and connections and then you're going to
sit down and like you're going to take
this away right I get that I can't think
of something that would be harder to do
as a parent um I just am seeing family
after Family Mortgage their souls for
sports and travel Sports and the sake of
whatever my kid wants to do I'm gonna
I'm gonna do it and the kids can't carry
that weight we end up burying our
children what you think David yeah yeah
it's that that's kind of my thinking
it's you know more we draw a line in the
sand and like yeah this is what we can
afford Y and I'm I'm sorry yep and I and
David honestly too if you don't do that
nobody else is this ice skating
Community isn't going to the the
trainer's not going to the the
championship tournament places aren't
going like no one else is going to do
that you literally could spend and spend
and spend and spend and and there's
nobody in the world that's going to be
like hey David you got to stop so that's
when Da that's when you and your wife
together have to say we have to we have
to put a boundary up because there's
nobody else on planet Earth that puts up
boundaries for us we have to create
those ourselves and if you don't
especially these little microcosms of
life and kids sports is one of them you
can just go down a train just like
John's saying and it's and you look up
and you guys have spent your retirement
I mean you've done all of this and I I
know I just it I just am so so cautious
especially and I would say this too
David even if you guys had the money it
would be an interesting conversation too
the urgency may not be there like at
like with the money there's a little bit
of a fine night we just we don't have
the money like we can't do that and
we're not going to stress ourselves out
and miss mortgage payment for ice G like
that's that's in like that's that's
insane we can't do that we're are adults
she's 14 and we have to make adult
mature decisions in our household and
run our household and then what comes
after that is what we have to decide but
we're not going to put ourselves in a
financial bind for this we can't we
won't and so you draw that line but even
if you had the money I think what John's
saying is interesting and I know it's so
controversial here's the deal I've got
friends that are athletic trainers at
universities yeah and they continue to
tell me that they're bringing 18 and 19
year olds with joint overuse injuries
that they see in geriatric populations
shoulders and knees and hips that were
not designed to do the same sport yes
day after day week after week year after
year since someone was a child and all
the way up through their bodies can't
handle that right um so if there's like
a and I and I don't know David what your
options are but my encouragement would
be hopefully to be able to find a group
to plug in whether it's a wreck and not
competition I mean I don't know what it
is for ice skating but like where she
can still do what she loves right and
enjoy it but it's just not at this high
specific level that is so narrow let me
intense for 14 you know if this is my
house expensive I would sit my son down
who's 13 almost here and I'd walk him
through our budget and then I would say
here's what it costs for rent here's
what it costs for electric water all
that food what we spend and then here's
what we got for this and this is our cap
Y and then I'm not just going to say it
in the vacuum but I'm going to show him
here's what we can afford that's right
create your free every doll budget today
the simplest way to budget for your life